[Music]
three two one action another cat the
case it'll seek oh yeah [ __ ] hot go on
haha pew hey guys welcome back to off
the record where we talk about whatever
we won't special guests kalila Bobby Lee
thank you thank you so much thank you no
I didn't fart again no she did in front
of you yeah but my farts are so heavy
they just linger that's it is residual
forties you know what your fart kind of
smelled a little bit like vomit how you
smell with your little mutant nose it's
a mutant no look at that
no no don't the nostrils are like
[ __ ] pores I hate it
what Donnie wasn't gonna do smells worse
isn't mine your million really smell
yours really why does your even your
buff sparks probably that's actually
what Bart stands for buff farts yeah
what if farting and farting is a real
weird thing huh it is I don't do it but
it's your what it's gasses I'm not a
doctor you're more sciency than that but
there's gas that's gets stuck in your
body right push it out you have to
release it right I think so
you can try to like you know not around
people or like give us a warning or
something yeah but what happens if you
just don't do it and you internally for
it yes my stomach hurts oh I just will
refuse to do it you're killing yourself
on the inside just to let you know just
as long as people think I'm cute I'm
alright I have to push it out but was
still thinking cute even if you fart
reduce disgust yes well I won't find
myself right there with you girlfriend
did you guys are so [ __ ] weird dude
[ __ ] if I don't fire I feel like it's
gonna shoot out like a geyser [ __ ] dude
yeah that's a [ __ ] he's charted before
yeah yeah I started a couple times I
shat in my cart what a month ago right
wait no he was that shirt but you're
saying chef I [ __ ] in the car oh god
did it start as a shark I like went okay
if you have to take a [ __ ] and it's in
if you're in public and you near in your
car like what is what do you do do you
pull over and then get out the car
depends what kind of [ __ ] is that the
the sinking feeling you try to find a
bath either way you get the [ __ ] out the
car
yes either way get the [ __ ] out of the
car thank you this [ __ ] decides
that he wants to crawl into the backseat
and [ __ ] in the back never left the car
lady on the floor what's wrong [ __ ] on
the floor because I didn't want it was
an emergency situation just jumped off
the door [ __ ] on the floor you put your
pants down and sat on the seat just to
loosen the seat in the car yeah okay
okay it's traffic a Prius thank you but
I'm never sitting in your [ __ ] car
with the don't thanks okay I mean but
I'm in traffic okay and I'm you know I
listen to some tunes you don't have my
iTunes with the Bluetooth yeah you know
listen to some tunes do you know
whatever the song is right go to and I'm
kind of in the traffic right and
obviously you know you do a little like
ninja fart
look a little you know I mean an
appetizer or whatever you go like that
yeah and when I did that I go that's not
good
because what happened was when I was
there was basically what if this is my
butthole it was air here which was the
fart I just zipped out but right the
package was all [ __ ] right
it's like on [ __ ] Space Mountain when
the one [ __ ] thing huh there's
another one coming from the back it's
exactly analogous a great analogy right
the geyser right you guys are the geyser
I'm afraid of right so I'm sick right
and then oh and I'm in traffic and I'm
on Barham and all that where there's no
I don't know where to go I don't even
know what Mariana is right exactly it's
nowhere land okay there's no places yeah
and in my head I'm like I have 20
seconds twenty to thirty second there's
nowhere to go cuz then you could just go
on the road it's traffic there's
thousands of cars it's by the freeway
been in traffic and I pass by someone
taking a [ __ ] outside their car seen
that that's more of a normal man than
what you did in the backseat no that's
not I'll tell you why inside question uh
are your seats cloth or leather please
say leather so Bobby you're sitting down
[ __ ] is about to come out what do you do
i I go I got a fine residential I pull
over
wait why residential my desk because I
don't want to go where like we're
Ventura and all the cars are it's really
congested yeah yeah yeah so I go off
into like a little bit of a hill like 20
seconds oh I'm sorry
I thought you were on the freeway I
think he's not on the freeway no no yeah
you're on a busy road you're off I go up
to the right I pull over and there's a
gigantic like um a garbage can when I
got me it was like one of those
dumpsters right I parked right in front
of that was a white one right and I go
oh how can I go up on you know me and in
my head I'm like no two seconds I have
two seconds oh so I crawled in the back
seat yeah [ __ ] show that shows you to
take that the [ __ ] time yeah
and I pull it down you were alone in
this car yes and I [ __ ] all over the
seat my pants my hands everything what's
the worst part is that he didn't have to
do his own cleaner you cleaned it I paid
my friend Jenna - do you want to break
up with it they want to build that
resentment so I called her and I was
like look we have a situation he was
like the money Jenny's a mother she's
odd you / mother of a couple of months
maybe like a hundred fifty bucks that's
not worth it I need the money
she showed up in her little hazmat suit
no oh she [ __ ] does it she's awesome
but she couldn't even fully clean it
because it's a cloth um you know car
seat oh well then I had to drive it to a
car wash when I put a ski mask on
because I didn't want the guy to see
what I look like see it would [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the backseat excuse me sir can
you please no this is the same place all
the time
different people sometimes it's Bobby
sometimes it's me sometimes it doesn't
matter they know who you are if you
already happen every person that cleans
it it's gonna be one [ __ ] Mexican
dude they're like [ __ ] again what the
[ __ ] is he smelling so after you [ __ ]
yourself you got back on the stereo with
hand a [ __ ] on it hands and he just
drove it yeah and I remember holding my
phone to call kalila you're crying
howling or what no I'm just tell her
what's happened I'm like I [ __ ] all over
myself this [ __ ] everywhere I don't know
what to do because of the driver's seat
and yeah it's all over the place you're
like this and it was spraying out you
crouch down like that and see I see I
see I see I see so what is it
NCS NCIS or something like that
I just don't understand like how did it
get all over the place
here's why I'm suspicious where I think
the fetish sort of plays into this whole
theory of mine because the poops weren't
watery or soft they were okay they were
it was borderline it was half hard half
you know Sunday it was half soft-serve
so if you really had to go and it was
about to blow out your ass it comes out
diarrhea yeah yeah yeah burning it
doesn't come out hard so like he didn't
think he has a fetish I think so I think
he is a proof fetish him and his brother
do well how do you know them okay when
he picks up poo be like our doctor [ __ ]
every single time he takes a deep inhale
and when I pull you know he's just a
picture of my tail poop he sticks his
head in the toilet bowl and yeah like
it's cocaine I do it like it's cocaine
now everything makes sense yeah when you
saw that poop it was literally like
finding the biggest crack rock you've
ever seen in your life like a crack and
you just like what is this yeah what do
you mean it was all over my body yeah
yeah I mean without I was smelling it
was high I was high on my own supply
puppy would have accidents inside the
house always I'll clean it always the
first to offer to clean a puppy though
well I like the smell of gasoline -
what's up pump gas the smell of gas deep
through like 1/3 and the rest is weak
I'm an adult 40-something thanks Bobby
I'll be dead in 23 years is interesting
when did you start like people I don't
like it she's just I'm just going along
with whatever experience maybe you like
poop I don't like poop that's not a poor
then I'm not an animal I'm fancy I go to
bestir I'm a fancy guy you know here's
what it is though here's here's what it
is okay and let's be honest we're
mammals are we not okay to be honest
about our animals or basically we're
animals and we have cognitive thinking
and and and we're we were of all are
mentally we're evolved but essentially
were just these animals like I have
daemul things not smell or [ __ ] humans
do to that type of thing yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's like the new thing to do
every time somebody does some weird
fucked-up [ __ ] they go we're animals
right do you think yeah yeah how long
have you guys been dating when you found
out about this shitty in the back of the
Prius story month ago now he thinks
you're weird cuz you're still here that
was the first accident you remember like
when he [ __ ] himself or whatever and
you're just somebody you know the
species watch it on someone's house
forward to that a 24-hour nano
all-you-can-eat on Korean barbecue
players it was a mistake and then I I
pulled over and I went to somebody's
house no I told you to eat a banana to
clog up oh yeah yeah yeah ate the banana
push it push it on more it's more food
pushes in the other way
that's a cool way to ease into it though
cuz you kind of feel bad like oh you had
a stomachache you had a go yeah yeah but
then if that would first experience was
the [ __ ] in the breeze yeah that would
be hardcore but that's what you know
with kalila it's like if I first dated
her if I was like I like we were a month
in obviously I would have got a hotel or
gone to spa and clean myself out and you
would HIGHLY well of course I would but
yeah because I feel so comfortable with
her and she's family and you know we're
each other 24/7 how do you get back to a
place where we're not handling at what
point did you get comfortable with it
like that really quickly in a year
that's not that fast you're - that's
pretty normal I think yeah yeah yeah but
here's the thing dude it's like you know
I don't want to I don't want to have
these self-conscious and around my
girlfriend asked me to be self-conscious
I think she wants you to have some
decency okay I'll make a deal with you
right now baby
babycakes I'm looking right at you I
promise you baby that from now on if I
[ __ ] my pants or I have any kind of poop
situation that I'll go to a hotel and I
won't even tell you about it Hotel -
[ __ ] no if I'm like it if I'm in the car
and I need prepping for the future when
I was on this is this actually happened
when I was on NCIS and there was a scene
were you and it's a long story
he already told us I did right yeah it
was cold it was rainy and then you just
oh you were you playing on NCIS CIA
agent which episode is is I I play one
guy I've done it I'm gonna do it again
was my third time doing it and I play a
guy named Ron Rio and I'm a CIA CIA
agent I have to see these episodes first
of all you know you know what you just
did there yeah when I told you that I
played a CIA agent you laugh like you
couldn't believe just finished saying
that you feel out
me as Populi we all know that's an actor
now say you can't do you dude is this
alright
I told you that I was playing a CIA
agent yes and you slap like you couldn't
believe it was no I was laughing I was
laughing because I pictured you in the
first episode right and you know how
like CIS has dead bodies but it's dead
it's just a pile of poop but you put
Chuck over it I'm just gonna tell you
right now I have a machine gun in the
show your man doing serious gun why I
pigeon shooting and then take hold I
don't think executive the guy that
created the show I go the first day of
work I'm like are you sure do you see me
you've got the job you're like you show
me because I don't have an audition you
wrote it for me all they had you in mind
see that's the powerhouse that you
that's what I'm saying though what's a
lot is fatigue basically I should my
fatigues yeah yeah yeah ask you to come
back yeah yeah these are good people
yeah but I am saying though that every
do they need other agent after us or we
could just laugh it up and left on my
career and yourself about um you know
it's so funny bullies like you always
like you got you too right I've lived
through it and I will survive again
alright because let me see this right
now right I will persevere offered after
this you can laugh and mock me all you
want
there's no after this work we're
technically in the career space beneath
you end of the day dude I will not quit
and you will not force me to quit all
rise against you guy friend that's some
Korean [ __ ] right there what what or
you have the exact revenge on nobody for
no reason
I know that's so creatively somebody
sorry my bad I forgot I'm [ __ ] around
with the Korean how come you were cases
using communication yeah always exactly
there's another thing that you've
noticed huh do you guys fight about that
he's a cat and you can't go to him with
your love and affection oh really he
will hiss and possibly switch right now
when you try to kiss him you just have
to wait until he's ready to give it to
you I have OCD you know that right what
does that do I'll tell you why this is
what she means by that [ __ ] okay
because like we'll be watching something
in the band right yeah and she'll just
stick a toe her toe and just put it into
my thigh like this or in like my leg
right here right in my head once she
touches me with one towel just to touch
me with the other two two more times I
have that OCD thing so then I'll go just
do it again
two more times I've done that before
right yeah and I'll do it two more times
yeah yeah it drives me crazy
but if you just receive it receive I do
receive the tow but you have to do it
two more times on that same spot it's
like in a movie theater I don't I can't
turn around because if I turn around I
have to turn around two more times
yeah so this is basically you see let's
say let's say you know me I'm gonna
movie that watching the movie like this
right if I turn around and look at
somebody like this I have to go like
this you like three yes so I'm a crazy
person in that way and I used to be like
that with door handles or if I saw
cracks all forget it I'm there all day
touching enemy and going I've been over
the years I've you know been trying to
not do it that's dull what about this
Laura Watson's I think and if I would
the seams oh yeah if you rewinds it he
has to rewind it
times two the same spot so when eyes
we're not sure for back there so like if
I ask him like hey can you go back
because I didn't hear what that guy said
yeah and then I'll have to wait till
after the third time he's done we
continue watching so your whining point
rewind it play yeah holding you this
whole time like he's not really no I
really am like that yeah I have these
weird OCD things and I don't know my
brother has to sleep as a - I don't know
where I get it but it's like it drives
me crazy so what happens if you can't
complete your three who dies in your
mind
in my head I'm gonna die or you start to
panic yeah I start panic like I'm gonna
die if I don't do it three times but
I've been now with the site with the
cracks on the road don't do it as much
with door handles I don't do it at all
if I'm at work I don't do what if I
don't want people think I'm crazy like
you take on these quirks to just just
have works from OCD I feel like you just
wanted like something interesting to
tell people so you started this right
and then it became it stuck and now you
mask you know to me like when he was
younger
uh-huh oh don't worry when you save the
forest before you sit up no you've
already talked about it on where he'll
sit outside of a coffee shop and he'll
read like you know Dostoevsky and play
chess and pretend like he's just this
you know intellectual intellectual like
man of the word had like a dusty husky
book and as people are walking by you
start reading it like this to show
people to cover it and you're playing
chess by yourself yeah
smoking yourself I'll tell you one thing
I did was those are sick I used to work
at this coffee shop called the panicking
and next door was this used bookstore
this guy Dennis ran it but she this guy
Dennis knew a bunch of like famous
authors or his friends write like a
horror s Thompson he knew would hang out
was back in the early 90s right he's
ancient he knew Allen Ginsberg so I knew
Allen Ginsberg was gonna be there at his
bookstore so I went and bought an
analyst book book like poetry but the
howl which is one of his book never read
it but I also turned it up to look like
like I went through some keeping that
dirt on and put in a hole you know I
mean and then I came up to you know
Ginsburg oh yeah ma'am big thank you
sign it
oh so he signed you know I mean a little
thing like you're right
and I don't know where this now but you
know I mean that's who I am I'm a poser
why did you do that for because I said I
was a poser [ __ ] naughty like what
feeling is my fake I'm a fit but what
did what feeling did you feel cool yeah
I look I felt cool I did something
hosiery well would you Facebook you know
under interests yeah of like authors and
[ __ ] like yeah yeah yeah I would just go
and write down [ __ ] at the Barnes &
Noble and I would type that in but you
know here's the thing though I bought
some books
and I ended up starting reading them and
I started to like books poser he thought
that was a pseudo intellectual and then
I actually became one because I started
reading the [ __ ] that I bought that's
good though see he here the same thing
with those skateboarders you grew up
with right because you would carry on a
skateboard but you don't know how to
skate oh you started to become a skater
because you're like [ __ ] it I might as
well never learned but I was friend held
it but I was friends with guys but the
attire stuck for dead near 30 years your
brother and he opened a skate shop yeah
do you pose too hard now you have to cut
your losses at a certain point so when
you got caught in my hate you don't
escape why the [ __ ] do I have a skate
shop then yes yes that's like a closeted
gay guy opening up a brothel there's
nothing like that yes you see I see what
you're saying now - yeah the thing is is
that listen I was around scanners they
all knew that I didn't I'm not talking
about like just local guys I'm talking
about pros
yeah like dudes like you know that
skated 4-0 or coin machine like real
thing right and they should come by this
copy shot used to work I had my own
skateboard and it looked like I had like
done slides and rail slides and blunt
slides on it
it's just you going like yeah at night
so it could make it look like you know
the grinds of trucks they would be like
okay do it ollie
and then that and I'd be like no my name
is holly yeah but my papi yeah yeah but
I mean I would try this not have the
balance for it yeah I find it so
interesting that you you're a poser but
you actually put a lot of work into it
that you could have just done learning
how to skate one stop without buying the
shadow without having without having to
figure out every terminology and skating
on part of that you could just learn how
to skate
yeah what can I say this the [ __ ] yes
when I was 23 years old yeah okay I was
working in a coffee shop at no money
never want to call it I had no future
how are you buying all this [ __ ] pose
what do you mean you said you had a tiny
friends all my friends would hang out
there all skater to give me the board
and deck and stuff and I knocked on a
door at a comedy club and when I did an
amateur night went up again I went up
again five years later I was on Jay Leno
with no connections I worked hard to get
there and I got on a sketch show it
yours on America sketch show so go [ __ ]
yourself about posing my friend kid can
ask Melissa I work my [ __ ] ass off
bro can ask use not no faker good what
does that have to do with escaping no
I'm just saying you're saying what
you're saying that I don't do anything
no I'm saying what you're saying so I
don't know how to do a that I don't care
well that's what I read our to see this
young one young one all right that pop
up ain't done yet alright and I'm still
in the game how did your neck disappear
you want to die on you wanted I dunno
oh you do you're an egg huh you
cross-eyed little [ __ ] you know a
little [ __ ] huh
you're not developed you're me you
weren't developing the womb it came in
like you look like mr. Potato Head just
chilling there oh yeah
your eyes are like her nostrils then
that's fast that's sad good [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh yeah kak all you want you
[ __ ] my baby okay
[Music]